all right let's go to Katy in Tennessee
hi Katy how are you hi thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up so I was introduced to
your program recently by my dad I have
been in debt since I was 18 years old
I've never been I'm 32 okay so problem
is if I want to start going through
these steps try to get debt-free for me
and my family I just need to know where
to start
and by that I mean I have some payday
loans which were terrible but I had was
in one of those situations where I had
no choice and I need I don't have any
savings whatsoever
I mean I'm paycheck to paycheck yeah
you're starving so what do you mind are
you single no I'm married what's your
what's your household income our
take-home is fifty-five thousand years
okay and how much you have in payday
loans
I have about five thousand to get them
paid off that's a lot it is a lot
okay and what other debts do you have I
have three thousand dollars in credit
card debt and then what else do I have I
have a house we bought a house maybe
step six what other debts do you have
not counting your house I have a pickup
payment and the pickup I need I know
seventeen thousand on it what else and I
think that's it oh and five hundred
dollars in student loans so those are
almost paid off good okay okay what
we're gonna do is put you on a written
budget on the every dollar app for your
phone or your computer you and your
husband are gonna sit down together
we're gonna raise our right hand and
swear we will never see the inside of a
restaurant again until we get this
stupid debt paid off
you guys make too much money to be this
broke you're disorganized and you're
wasting the crap out of money and
therefore you create emergencies and
then you live emergency to emergency and
it makes you broker I've been there
myself that's how I can smell it yeah
[Applause]
basically what it is is just we have to
sound so long until something bad
happens yeah it's like you know when you
really really really broke your life
starts looking like a country song
everything that can go wrong will you
know keep the dog on the street he's
gonna get hit I mean it's bad you know
and that's the kind of stuff you have to
work on here so so what we're gonna just
get on this tight budget every dollar
has an assignment on paper before the
month begins in the every dollar budget
the budget is free okay jump online
download the every dollar app it's free
all right okay once you're doing that
then baby step one is you need to get
$1,000 to keep little emergencies from
causing you to go into a tailspin and
drama queen mode again okay that little
bitty thousand dollar it's not a full
emergency fund but it's a little starter
emergency fund and some stupid little
thing happens like a tire blows on the
car or something
then you don't have to go into panic
mode and go down to stupid land again
which is what you call payday lenders
yeah that's exactly what happened 840
percent interest
that's insane this is rape pillage and
plunder no one is left alive in the
village when you finish with these
people okay they burn everything to the
ground they're horrible it's the worst
scummiest industry on the planet so what
we're gonna do then is we're gonna work
the debt snowball where you list your
debts smallest to largest
you pay minimum payments on everything
but the little one and you attack the
little one only I'm gonna flip one item
out of your debt snowball and that's the
stupid payday loans we're gonna put them
at the top okay and here's what I want
you to do I'm talking you have no life
you are having a garage sale you're
putting the cat on Craigslist and the
dog on eBay we're selling everything
okay and you're gonna get 2,500 a month
for two months out of your budget you're
gonna go pay these morons off and don't
you ever go back on that property again
ever
they're killing you kid they're skinning
you alive
don't go back over there again these are
nasty humans stay away from them nothing
good happens at their place you get them
paid off and then you work your debts
off smallest to largest hold on I'm
gonna send you a copy of the book the
Total Money Makeover to show you how to
do every bit of this you can do it and
you call me back if you need some help